welcome of course to another very
special edition of a beginner breakdown
I've got great news I am now on Twitter
as soon as I get a hundred followers I
will start tweeting you can follow me at
the real Mike Homer at big comb STL all
right so be sure to treat and I'll
follow you and we can I'll have a lot of
fun okay
and today you might remember this guy
Alex come on up here Alex from the yeah
from the season premiere interrupting my
lecture so as a reprimand I am going to
analyze his games you're in a lot of
trouble today Alex and today he has the
black pieces
it was hot off the presses okay so here
it goes and as you all know Ben Feingold
grandmaster Ben triangle is now our
resident back from an undisclosed
location and but he's back so it's good
to be back alright so so the Tina's got
the black pieces he's playing the most
simple-minded opening efore a5 so that's
all we can really grasp so far so that's
what he's up to
so he's already got a cool pathway for
this Bishop so guess where he decides to
do hey get up so we can have this cool
pathway to so get a lot of options okay
Alex like options you should just decide
one and go for it and of course of
course he can't resist after playing g6
deflected pitch to c5 that's the whole
point of it alright so if you already
have an escape for your Bishop there's
no reason to create another one okay
let's bet you if you're not gonna put
the bishop there anyway alright so white
just goes for Knight to d5 so now if it
brings us knife
six he can just take it but he decides
against it he plays c3 and so black says
free pawn so is there any good move
white can do here if I was white I would
probably just get castled here but he
goes for it he goes for d4 and black
retreats Holly should take it but okay
he retreats his Bishop to to nap the
best square but it does protect the pot
so white decides to play Bishop to e3
over protecting this pawn so they have a
lot of different trades they can do
there's a piece of blacks and whites
camp that is easily attacked but he
decides to protect the point much better
for this Bishop would be up here
preventing a castle all right
so castle now he decides to attack the
knight so ideas like f5 would be
horrible I think I would just lose
everything to discover checks right
what's the crusher there's got to be a
crusher somewhere I mean you could just
play Knight to b6 if you really wanted
to be lazy and that calculate anything
right Knight to c7 Knight takes Knight
takes thee seven even better than b6
yeah alright so so don't play your F
pawn please all right so so he decides
the tank finally and when he takes back
he's got a really cool way he can he can
protect the night here anybody see it
how would you protect the knight in this
position rook to e8
would be good he's decided support is
Queen to e8 which is a disaster for a
lot of reasons so a journey just can't
wait to say it
excellent okay so a lot of people at
home with Perry say no well you can't
play it left so cuz bishops can move
backwards alright so after Queen takes
Queen takes and the knight check and not
very good so so that third move g6 is
really just crushing this guy here but
don't worry
his opponent didn't sit and instead he
plays the move B for threatening b5
alright what a threat there right there
head so he decides I'm just gonna take
and he's like I'm gonna take it and then
I'm gonna take it with Chuck and he's
got to be really careful here so do you
think he gets out of this Queen Knight
disaster no walks right into it gets
closer to that alright so d6 activates
the bishop here okay
rook a to b one attacks the bishop and
can you see a decent move for a black
here besides the grandmaster and
remember like last week we were looking
for checks and captures and all the good
stuff
oh now that I gave a gern the hint he's
like oh yeah now I got it I'm sure you
would have had it anyway
all right during what is it
doesn't get the job done remember we're
looking for shacks and captures which
queen a4 is neither so at home do you
got it you see a big check
August finally got all right yes sir
93 check yes fork okay so let's see what
happens actually in the game all right
exactly as I predicted all right and
then he's like all right nope no problem
I get it I got it you got it okay all
right so he just lost the exchange and
now this Bishop is under attack let's
see if he sees it okay so he protects it
with a five dangerous okay notice this
Bishop doesn't have many spaces to go to
just really a three and c3 so I might
think of things like this and that the
trap it but those are just ideas
all right you can always just prevent
the bishop from going to jeepers
whatever you want to do c6 g4 oh he's
preparing his King side attack now okay
so so white is losing this game so why
not just go for an all-out attack he
still has this bishop that can go to h6
well what she should be doing right and
uh just winning back to the exchange
here so eventually he'll get to it it
looks like alright d5 attacks the bishop
so we retreat the bishop and now he gets
this f5 move in so now that the rook can
finally move he decides to attack it all
right Rick f7 King G - all right we
probably want to get our night up on e5
down attack King G to F takes G 4 and
now 95 the fork
Black's would take with check ok just
cuz this rook is under attack here
doesn't necessarily mean he has to move
it he could just play check and of
course White's got to get out of the
check good luck I guess with that move
so ok so he moves the rook anyway
Rick f6 Bishop Mitacs the rook now he's
like ok I can take with check King g3
and now his rooks attacked me so he
moves it rook f8 right protects all his
pieces with f4 and now he offers the
trade good he's up material he might as
well start trading the material except
that Bishop is doing a really good job
protecting this pawn so I might not want
to but he wants to Bishop f5 so you
can't resist the take take
how would you take back this pawn with
the rook or the King or doesn't matter I
would take back with adjourn what are
you gonna say the Brooke yeah and I love
that my Brooks on this h-file here I
don't want my King on the HPL alright
but he takes back with the King Queen 6
excellent ok threatening rook takes
Bishop check so he's got to get oh yes
oh joy
yes he's also threatening Brooke take
spot he can do it all okay he's
threatening discovered check okay so
let's see what we got which so you would
take the night in this position yeah
okay so so he's like all right he's
bring as Kenya wake up shirt
toward the enemy camp here or right
let's see if it works out for him you
activate the king the king can become a
warrior as we know yes all right
so excellent Bishop to e7 threatening
check I love it
and now he's like I wait I'm going to
get on offense here if you had to guess
this game will be over in about four
moves who do you think who do you think
adjourn yeah considering Alex latina is
playing black yeah good good guess okay
alright so he gets Shaq and guess what
he's gonna get another check here and
he's still gonna manage to lose them for
us all right all right Rick f4 check
King H King to g3 yeah so so he he's
really scared that this Brook is under
attack really scared like he's never
been so scared and this rook is also
under attack so whichever rook place
that fate it doesn't matter so he's like
I got this big attack going look at me
look at me
we'll look at you okay so what does
white play here come back up here and
and let's look at him like that
yeah alright hopefully everybody can see
how white how I turned turn this whole
thing around adjourn
is that a factor as a gas yeah that's
how I did win that's the that's the
winning of checkmate game over
okay so even though he got down orderly
yeah he couldn't he couldn't seal the
deal all right
so but that's okay you know you win some
you lose some and then the next one we
might actually show one where he uh he
wins
maybe all right so when this one alex
has the white pieces and he's like I've
had enough of all this opening theory
considering I don't know what anyway
okay so I'm just gonna play play logical
moves and uh and just see what happens
all right
so so there's a little kid that comes to
club a lot he like plays the same like
first seven moves every game he plays
and with mixed results but he doesn't
have to learn any opening theory so so
let's see if it works out so see four
black plays d6 why do you think I hate
the movie six in this position adjoint
right right it's like this guy is gonna
have no hope for the rest of the game I
don't even think he moves the whole game
either so I mean it's just this every
move you make very very important
because it all leads up you know you
make one mistake early in your life got
to recover somehow alright so this is a
big big mistake I mean you're paralyzed
in your future for this guy alright so
don't play like that
all right so g3 c6
so now everybody thinks PI from the last
game he's gonna play III right but he
he's wise enough and he plays Bishop the
g2 gets him on this long day I know good
job Knight f6 and Knight to c3 and now
he plays Bishop to b4 threatening to
double his pawns but it's like I don't I
don't care about double pause I mean I
don't care whatever double pawns as a
very dubious player once said double the
poll
double the strength all right and I
proceeded to whoop them ten times in a
row every said that all right so so
guess what he doesn't do anything about
it like a journey or pile a like Queen
to b3 Queen to c2 here that way if he
takes you know you don't have double
pawns right all right so so and say he's
like I don't care whatever double pawns
I'll take them and so he dead managed
the capture toward the center so that
was decent and so blacks like out you
know what I'll do you a favor all right
I know you don't want double pawns so
I'll let you I'll let you just get rid
of him he's like okay thanks and now now
if you were good at chess all right and
you were playing black you have four
options how to take this pawn back and
obviously even listen to me you would
know exactly which way to take back our
Alex latina so of course he picks the
the wrong answer yeah Alex latina even
though I probably gone over this game
with them before you actually want to
take with your epon to activate your
bishop now and that computer let's see
what the computer says the computer so
funny
yeah a PI gets it wrong to the computer
alright so the computer the computer
sided with the Alex latina
yeah it gives the knight a square it
gives them it gives a knight a square
yep so what move should we play in this
position obviously Bishop a3 as cited by
both the father and the son okay who
said it first we'll never know all right
so be safe all right
now he should obviously get castled here
but instead he gets his night going into
enemy territory without a specific plan
great idea
okay still Queen to c7 so he protects it
Knight B to d7 attacks it so you know
just pin it right if you can pin
something pin it Queen a 486 actually
gets castled he's got to watch out for
these checks obviously right now check
would be no good because Bishop could
take it but he's got to be watching out
for the checks all right so he attacks
the Queen and now he's like all right my
Queens attacked all right I'll just
simply move it everything's fine okay
what is everything fine if you're
playing the black pieces danger yes
threatening checkmate okay so you gotta
watch out for it Knight takes Knight yes
yes yes excellent pawn takes should
Queen come down and take this pawn no
because you would get checkmated so he's
got to move the knight she move his
knight here anybody no cuz he would get
checkmated so you got oh you got to
watch out for these checkmate
so he plays Knight to e4 anybody that's
anybody would just take this Knight
right away okay and you would have funny
puns
but he decides to protect this pawn to
slow way to slow and now that gives
black a chance to play a really good
move here to relieve some of the
pressure from his queen so look this
East 7 is such a crucial square right
gives the Queen well if the Queen moves
off of move off of protecting East 7
game's over
so who can help
some of the pressure yes adjourn what Oh
so-so adjourn suggest a five which
unfortunately okay so he's got to get
the Queen off the thing off this
diagonal line but he can take with Chuck
and that would hurt Brooke a7 yes yes
yes yes okay seven so now he's got some
backup okay so now he decides to take
the knight too slow too slow too slow so
he attacks the pawn and now white could
protect it with Bishop could be seven
maybe if he wants to but but he's got to
watch out for ideas like rook F one here
so he decides to play f5 and just clog
it up but obviously he never heard of us
special rule in chess called fun percent
no never heard of it all right
so what um percent is is if you have a
pawn on your fifth rank that means
you're in enemy territory on row number
five and the opponent makes a move
moving this pawn up twice and it lands
on that exact same row of yours you can
capture it as if he only moved up once
so you could just pretend like in this
instance that he played f6 and so
whenever they play f6 you just take it
and then white just crushing here but
you know his opponent took a risk like
this guy he doesn't know couple honest
and he was right he was right
so he's like darn and so so he'll just
attack and now he attacks the rook
you've got to take it all the way back
and now black makes a horrible air so
he's finally like kind of cooled off
this attack okay he's got two people
protecting
the he's got two people protecting east
seven you know he could even play rook
g8 and then g6 rook she says just to
have the whole gang there okay well you
won't want to play that though but but
anyway he's fine okay but he's really
nervous still about it so so what's a
bad move black your play here so plays
Queen to e7 okay it's true it crushes
all the whites hopes of checkmate but it
it deliberately gave up an exchange for
no good reason
adjourned you have a question all right
but adjourned thinks he's got a worse
mood than Queen to e7 green a5 green i 5
is the worst move so completely 7 is
well let's have a big debate about it
okay
alright so there's a lot of bad moves in
the position and he found one of them
okay that's why he's the Graham rest you
can find the gun moves and the bad moves
alright so sorry it so it anyway he uh
he wimps out and and does this so now
Alex
yeah sorry it's all coming back okay
it's all coming back hopefully no f5 and
then he goes D 3 g5 boom and then the
the week trade and alright so now so now
what does white one
well obviously wants to win this endgame
right but what does he really want for
his rooks in this position open files
right it's like you've been hanging out
of the lesson with me before yeah open
pass just open the file break open the
file don't complain about it like I
don't have any open files like the move
d4 in this position would be awful
alright so he takes takes and now he
decides he's gonna start playing really
good it's just good okay better better
sooner than later alright so so what's a
really cool move that white has yes yeah
it's right right in his face yeah I'm
coming for you I'm attacking all your
stuff excellent so once again this guy's
gonna gonna be like oh no and so rook
takes King takes and white white peasant
I mean obviously is crushing right now
what I mean he wants to get the job done
fast right so a lot of people that never
watched my chair lecture would be like
yelling about hey let's check on let's
check them it's so cool to check them
no don't check on play you're gonna win
I mean you're gonna win all his pawns it
doesn't matter what he does right it
would but but in order but you're giving
up now his King has major activity he's
gonna come down eat that he's gonna call
me that
eat that and then race that beep on to
victory okay so what rook f7 you don't
check you say ha ha you're on the you're
gonna be forever on the back row and you
can't do nothing this keep in this
position you know this Bishop thanks to
move one e six has never got to play one
move the whole game so actually this
king is still a better piece
he's got more chances to take stuff than
this bishop in this end game so if we
can just contain the king he has no hope
okay and we love it when the opponent
has no hope all right so what can he do
now
all right so he saves the pawn with h5
and then adjourn what rook a seven
attack attack the protected pawn you
better have okay all right that's good
so he decides he's a little lazy he
sighs I just move it over one alright so
attacks that one here and now what would
you play work g5 no so if you play
Brooke the g5 guess what you let them
get off the off the back row right
whereas you could play rook to h7 and
now you you keep them on the back row
you want to keep the guy on the back row
as long as possible it might not matter
it's true it doesn't matter in this
position if he plays g5 or h7 but in a
more tightly contested endgame adjourned
every temple matters okay so keep that
king contained but of course Alex plays
rook - all right so so a5 and he's just
gonna mop him up now rook takes h v b4
this is the most critical position in
this game this is the only way Y can
screw it up
so and thankfully he doesn't so what
should white play in this position yes
yeah just take it right eliminate the
threat
all right take on b4 all right so uh
rook g5 Bishop a6 he takes Bishop c4 and
then we just take the pawn and even
takes this pawn where you can just take
his pawn right and the game is over
that's essentially how it ends
I mean it's pretty bad the good job okay
so he got on the board with a victory
and now we get to see his final game
where he plays the most embarrassing
move of all time
he is the black pieces actually in this
game so it's very exciting so we'll do
the old control f and okay so it's Alex
latina playing up black and let's see
what he does alright so d4 Knight f6
Knight f3 and so so of course black
plays the dubious be six here okay so
once again just killing all hopes of
this Bishop ever doing anything so so so
white saw how bad his LightSquared
Bishop is so he decides to get in the
fun and kill his own dark square bishop
okay so you want your bishops outside of
the pawn chain right Bishop f4 or Bishop
g5 even then III is acceptable but when
you play e3 right now you know you're
killing your mobility
your pieces for no unforced errors for
no good reason
d5 so now he's like well I can't get the
bishop out this way thanks to my last
move I have to get them out this way now
b3 knight c6 Bishop to b2 but is this
Bishop like a monster and b2 no because
he's behind his pawn chain d4 yup
alright so wait
Alex plays his Bishop out he's like I
don't want to be checked even though he
has no plans of being checking him there
so whatever all right so so black gets
castle that's good alex has been getting
castled in these games and he's doing ok
so Bishop to d3 this is a really good
diagonal for for this Bishop here
threatening checks and all sorts of fun
stuff so black plays a 6 here and white
finally gets castle so he's gonna play
b5 no because if we sacrifice here the
knight can take and and you have nothing
yeah anybody can take huh but you know
just to be just to be safe you take with
the night all right Knight to e4 Knight
to e4 putting C the night is like a huge
defender in this position I would not
want to trade it but he's like I don't
care give me the double pawns Knight to
e7 and now white plays a very very
speculative move Bishop to e2 alright
you don't want to be just retreating for
no good reason and the bishop was so
beautiful on this diagonal - alright so
black plays c6
white gets as a night out black gets the
battery going the Queen Bishop on the
same line attacking h2 here
so now he decides to take and that that
really just makes all of blacks plans
come to light because now he must remove
the defender of h2 he goes backwards so
Bishop takes h2 check King moves over he
doesn't want to get his Bishop trapped
here after g3 so he decides very smartly
to move it back out of harm's way and
the knight takes the pawn now and black
plays f5 to attack the knight so he
takes the bishop queen takes the bishop
and now white plays the move f4
okay so so black sees Alex sees wow this
King is on an open H file I really want
to get all my pieces on that H file okay
so let's see if his plan works rook to
f6 now now White's like hey he just put
his rook on f6 I wonder if I have a
discovered attack anybody see a
discovery all right so let's see if we
can see the discovery first and then
we'll ask ourselves is our discovery any
good all right all right a lot of people
are getting their their hands raised all
right all right
adjourn what's the discovery why
excellent that's the whole reason it
doesn't work is because after d5 we just
played in the game he didn't he needs to
calculate he Ganges leo discovery cuz he
should have asked himself before that is
why did he play rook to f6
obviously that checked you so even
though you see a discovery
he gets that inner Mesa or in between
move rook h6 check King moves and now we
have an option once again we have four
different ways we can capture this pawn
does anybody have any ideas which is the
best I know what you're gonna say so
just say it well you got a pick one see
that's people be quiet wait because it
pins the knight we don't want to put our
pieces and pins right but maybe the
computer does and so my vote is a pawn
so let's see if the computer just says
I'm an idiot they're all good
Knight takes d5 obviously unbelievable
this computer gives me no respect all
right so so Alex the team is playing
like the computer is like yeah up with
my up on my own knight in a pin no no
problem no problem at all no problem at
all
alright so now where do you think blacks
Queen wants to get to whether it's
dubious or not yes okay yep so so whites
actually gonna help him like expedite
that process okay so first things first
he attacks the Queen thinking wow I
attack the Queen look at me this is not
good he wants to wait till this rooks on
b8 or something and then that's when you
give the give the attack but okay but he
can't wait okay so he's like thank you I
want to go here anyway thank you thank
you thank you thank you and so he's like
alright and so
I'll make it even more tempting
differentiate a CO 2 H 4 so he's like
all right any like he's all oh so now
[ __ ] up the f3
now I find the move even the computer
can't even say anything but let's we'll
look at this so so black
he's got Alex has his whole this whole
dream come true he's got everybody on
the H file but the big question is is it
any good the mystery
so you just analyze the checks I check
you there he goes there I check you
there you might just go back and laugh
at you and you're like darn I didn't do
nothing
all right but we could get right into
space check King their check and once
again you might just go back and laugh
at you so it doesn't look like our
checks are doing anything so just
because you have a check see a check
doesn't necessarily mean you want to
play it but I mean you really can't
resist right or can you I don't know but
Queen g3
well why don't I just play like well
maybe I just I don't know when I play I
can play anything well what's the threat
that rook here so it's tough so so my
idea in the position and we'll see if
the computer relates it is bring my rook
in the game and then get them on the d5
and then we might be threatened some
good stuff so let's see what the
computer says see how but see how in
this position the computer is tap to
moves will not be a check ok so just
because you have the big check if you
can't calculate it out to bait or you
could hope its mate but it's obviously
not doesn't necessarily mean you have to
plant so are we looking for the worst
move
so queen up to might actually be the
worst move fortunately he plays anybody
else green f2 looks pretty bad that
might be the officially worst move
anybody else have a guess yes Queen g5
that's pretty bad too but it's close
queen h5 okay so get that Queen in the
same Lane as the bishop and the Queen
and now he's so mad that he just took
the Queen of course he's gonna take the
bishop and then and the wild line game
over game over yeah it was an accident
okay
it's all an accident whenever you lose
just an accident oops
yeah that's yep
that's what happens all right so there's
there's the games of the great Alex
Cetina all right so if you're out at the
club and looking to whoop up on somebody
just come in and say hey let me play
Alex latina alright alright hopefully
all follow me on Twitter the real Mike
comer and we'll have a lot of fun all
right thank you yes the real might
comment why I have zero Fowler so
alright thanks
oh yeah big calm SPL